m
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 25 mars
nièvre au néo bourgeois analyste des
départements aux mesures de freinage
renforcé conférence de presse tout à
l'heure d'olivier verront le ministre de
la santé qui évoque une situation
préoccupante surtout en ile-de-france
dans les hauts de france et en région
paca toujours deux objectifs avoir
réalisé une injection de vaccin 10
millions de français d'ici à la mi-avril
et conserver les écoles ouvertes leurs
enfants sommet virtuel une réunion
marquée par la participation de joe
biden est une première pour le 46e
président américain avec en filigrane
les tensions diplomatiques avec la chine
et la russie et puis un mot d'ordre la
vaccination contre le coc bit qui patine
faute de doses disponibles alors
l'europe des vingt-sept pourra-t-elle
survivre à l'épidémie ou tout du moins
sortir indemne de cette crise sanitaire
inédite ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face
alors qu'aux états unis des millions
foyers commencent à recevoir leurs
chèques financé par un plan de relance
massif les européens eux ne voit
toujours rien venir annoncée l'été
dernier le plan de 750 milliards d'euros
n'entrera en vigueur qu'à la fin de
cette année n'arrive t elle pas trop
tard par rapport aux états unis autant
de questions qu'elle l'économiste
jacques sapir tentera de répondre dans
son édito échos ce soir mes patrons de
facebook twitter et google auditionné
cet après midi par les parlementaires
américains pour répondre aux élus sur le
problème de la désinformation outre
manche le quotidien britannique the
guardian révèle un guide des règles de
modération de facebook justement une
fuite leur a donné accès à trois cents
pages distribué en interne et les
résultats vous le verrez sont
surprenants
[Musique]
nous avons de développer ses titres
direction tout de suite la place de la
république où des tentes de migrantes
sont actuellement monté à l'initiative
de plusieurs collectifs qui sont
présents près de quatre mois après une
première opération similaire qui avait
vu les forces de l'ordre d'intervenir
mona mots dès lors vous êtes en direct
sur place bonsoir monaco les la
situation
la situation est bien regarder juste
derrière moi stéphanie plusieurs
centaines d'hommes de femmes d'enfants
se sont installés sur cette place de la
république ils sont arrivés aux
alentours de 18h30 la présence policière
est plus tôt
secrète contrairement à l'action qui a
eu lieu en novembre 2020 alors justement
pour en parler je suis avec philippe
caroit et c'est un bénévole
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
alors on l'a vu plusieurs centaines de
personnes sont installées ici quel est
le but de cette occupation issia place
de la république
ok ce soir c'est la nuit de la
solidarité et nous le constat qu'on fait
quand même depuis des mois depuis au
moins un an de panne est même avancé qu'
il ya énormément de gens dans les rues
et qu'elle a de plus en plus on
distribue pour vous donner une idée ce
soir il ya une maraude de notre
collectif alimentaire
on va distribuer à peu près 900 repas
mardi on a distribué à peu près 900
repas sauf que depuis novembre
il ya une chasse à l'homme dans les rues
de paris qui fait que les gens qui
essaient de se poser quand ils sont un
peu trop visibles sont chassés nous ce
qu'on voit dans nos maraudes c'est qu'il
ya des centaines et des centaines de
personnes mais c'est invisible alors
qu'un campement c'était plus visible est
ce qu'on rend visite ce soir c'est
justement ça les invisibles ce soir on
rend visible et invisible qu'elle est
quel est le profil de ces migrants de
ces personnes qui sont présentes ici
alors il ya plusieurs profils puisque ce
soir ça collectif réquisitions qu'elle
est à l'initiative de ce hack qui a
composé en fait de plusieurs
associations et collectifs
donc nous solidarité migrants wilson
mais aussi le dal qui dit qui y est
plutôt sur les
les mal logés et les sans le sans
domicile fixe et aussi utopia 56 et
aussi enfants d'afghanistan est
d'ailleurs voilà plusieurs appareils
d'exil plusieurs associations qui ont
des publics très différents mais qui ont
quand même un point commun c'est qu'on
trouve beaucoup beaucoup de gens nous
les uns et les autres à la rue donc on a
décidé d'unir nos forces pour demander
une chose simple c'est l'application de
la loi la loi de réquisition c'est à
dire qu'en france il ya une loi qui
permet aux préfets à l'état en fait de
réquisitionner des logements vides et on
a plus de cent mille appareils croatie
113000 et voyez il ya quand même
quelques centaines de personnes donc en
gros
pourrait relever immédiatement ces gens
monde allemand on a déposé en décembre
412 demande de réquisition pas une seule
à bouger donc on a occupé une école dans
le 16e arrondissement en janvier qu'a
permis de mettre à l'abri 160 170
personnes
en février on a occupé l'hôtel dieu qui
avait envie de mettre à l'abri en plein
plan grand froid 70 personnes qui sera
légué star qui aurait dormi à la rue ce
soir là par leurs enfants
et donc on continue ses actions là
jusqu'à ce que la loi de réquisition
soit appliquée car en quelques années le
but de cette de cette occupation est ce
que ça de rester toute la nuit c'est de
perdurer ici sur cette place de la
république
alors ya une partie de l'équation qui
dépend pas de nous c'est à dire que nous
ici d'avoir s'est quand même fait en
lien avec des exilés des réfugiés les
gens qui dorment dans la rue donc toute
façon s'ils n'ont pas ici ils vont aller
ailleurs dormi dans la rue donc en gros
ce qu'on demande nous c'est que ce soir
dès ce soir
il ya une solution pérenne et puis aussi
qui peut qui peut être l'application de
la loi de réquisition tout simplement
donc après quand je dis qu'une partie de
l'équation qui ne dépend pas de nous
c'est nous si les pouvoirs publics en
gros trouve une solution ce soir il ya
plus personne ce soir ici s'y trouvent
pas de solution nous on va rester ou pas
voilà est-ce que vous craignez
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre on
se souvient notamment de novembre 2010
où il ya eu une évacuation à ses muscles
et les brutalités ce sont les brutalités
des forces de l'ordre vis-à-vis des
exilés notamment c'est pas une nouveauté
c'est ce que les médias ont vu en avant
parce que ça a été ça s'est fait ici
c'était sous l'essuie tout le monde nous
c'est ce qu'on constate quand même
depuis des années et c'est ce qu'on voit
d'ailleurs depuis
après voilà ce soir il ya du monde il ya
au moins 300 ans je pense à peu près 300
400 personnes
il ya plein de gens qui filme il ya des
médias qui sont là et on pense que ils
ont quand même compris la leçon qu'ils
ont eue en novembre l'année dernière et
que
en gros on ne seront peut-être plus
disposés à trouver des solutions
durables et pérennes voilà mais nous ce
qu'on veut c'est pas mal l'application
de la loi de réquisition
merci beaucoup a fini peu à carreaux
pour ce témoignage
vous l'avez entendu ces familles pour le
moment tout va dépendre de comment va se
dérouler la nuit est pour l'instant
contrairement à l'action de pointe y
avait eu lieu en novembre 2020 et bien
la présence policière elle est très
timide très discrète puisqu'en novembre
toute cette place est bien elle était
encerclée par les forces de l'ordre
ce soir c'est différent l'ambiance est
plus plus plus disons plus bon enfant
regarder juste derrière moi il y à un
orchestre qui jouait de la musique
plusieurs passants s'arrêtent notamment
pour discuter avec ces migrants avec eux
qui sont qui parmi eux il ya des enfants
des femmes qui sont juste ici alors vous
l'avez vu tout dépendra de comment va se
dérouler cette soirée ici en tout cas
ils comptent rester sur cette place de
la république
toute la nuit oui merci mon amour et
laure accompagné de l'uqat ua pour les
images en direct de la place de la
république à paris
je vous le disais en titre restrictions
renforcées dans les départements de
l'aube de la nièvre et du rhône verdict
de la conférence de presse hebdomadaire
d'olivier ferrand ils viennent s'ajouter
à la liste des 16 départements déjà
confiné ont fait le point avec grégoire
douce et les mesures de freinage
s'étendent petit à petit lob la nièvre
et le rhône rejoignent les 16
départements placés précédemment en
confinement par l'exécutif
l'annnonce du ministre de la santé était
pressenti depuis plusieurs heures à
compter de ce vendredi minuit et pour
quatre semaines donc dans ces trois
départements le couvre-feu continue de
s'appliquer
de 19 heures à 6 heures les
rassemblements en extérieur ne doivent
pas dépasser six personnes les
déplacements sont autorisés de 6 heures
à 19 heures lorsque c'est dans un rayon
inférieur à 10 km sans attestation sans
limitation de durée
on vous demande d'avoir sur vous un
justificatif de domicile comme une pièce
d'identité entre 6 heures et 19 heures
si vous dépassez 10 km depuis votre
domicile mais également de 19h à 6h
cette fois ci quelle que soit la
distance vous devrez avoir une
attestation dérogatoire pas de
confinement généralisée pour l'instant
malgré des indicateurs épidémique qui ne
s'infléchit ce pas
le gouvernement se donne une dizaine de
jours pour évaluer l'efficacité des
mesures en place
olivier ferrand qui explique également
qu'en raison des variants et de la
vaccination déjà avancé des seniors les
patients en réanimation sont de plus en
plus jeunes quant aux écoles
elle reste ouverte c'est ne seront
fermées qu'en dernier recours mais
s'apprête à voir leur protocole
sanitaire une nouvelle fois renforcé
pourquoi est-ce que nous maintenons les
écoles ouvertes la fermeture des écoles
c'est une décision de dernier recours
que nous voulons à tout prix éviter
parce que nous savons qu'elle a des
conséquences très lourdes sur le
développement des enfants et sur le
quotidien des parents nous ne nions pas
que le virus peut aussi se transmettre à
l'école puis de l'école vers les
familles
c'est pourquoi avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
nous travaillerons à des protocoles
sanitaires renforcés en sus de ceux qui
sont déjà mises en place dans les
établissements scolaires l'éducation
fait donc toujours partie des priorités
affichées par les autorités depuis le
très strict premier confinement les
écoles n'ont plus fait
objet d'une fermeture généralisée elle
sommet aujourd'hui du conseil européen
par vidéoconférence le contrôle accru
des exportations de vaccins hors de l'ue
est au centre des discussions des
dirigeants partagés sur la question mais
unis dans la volonté d'accélérer leurs
campagnes de vaccination
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement des
vingt-sept vont être rejoints dans la
soirée par joe biden un symbole fort du
renouveau de la relation transatlantique
l'europe qui patine on l'aura compris un
nom sa campagne de vaccination l'europe
qui courent après des doses déjà cette
semaine de retard dans le calendrier
l'europe égratigné par ces populations
impatient de voir le bout du tunnel
alors l'europe des vingt-sept
pourra-t-elle survivre à l'épidémie où
tu dois sortir indemne de cette crise
sanitaire inédite c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
et avec nous pour en parler finit pas
muraire économistes vous êtes à clessé
dans la famille on va dire des
souverainistes pour vous situer bonsoir
philippe murray remercie d'être avec
nous avons sauté françois pour les
mathis journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être là
françois paul et mathis et emmanuel
macron a donc reconnu des couacs 1 hier
soir l'europe est un peu un dizaine en
matière de vaccination a avoué a admis
le président français je vous propose de
l'écouter avant de vous faire réagir
on n'a pas pensé que ça irait aussi vite
la recherche en europe s'est faite
beaucoup d'ailleurs de la recherche
mondiale sur les vaccins vient d'europe
les américains us ont eu un mérite dès
l'été 2020 ils ont dit on met le paquet
et on y va
et donc ils ont plus ils ont eu plus
d'ambition que nous et le quoi qu'il en
coûte qu'on a appliqué pour les mesures
d'accompagnement eux l'ont appliquée
pour les vaccins la recherche
le mérite en tout cas du mea culpa
philippe murray rôle c'est dans une
famille quand il ya des problèmes on a
tendance un petit peu à se rejeter la
faute c'est ce qui risque de se passer
lors de ce sommet ce soir on risque de
se faire quelques reproches je crois pas
que l'union européenne d'une famille
d'ailleurs vous on parle de l'europe
mais l'europe on parle pas du continent
européen keep de survivre ou pas les
pays européens survivre ou forcément
l'union européenne c'est la machine
bureaucratique qui est au dessus des
états nations historiques de la france
de l'allemagne de l'italie de l'espagne
et qui en serre et qui est administré
une administration tout simplement
effectivement il ya des ratés depuis le
début en fait il ya un an y avait pas de
masse parce qu'on avait de localiser les
usines à cause de l'union européenne pas
de gel hydroalcoolique parce que l'union
européenne est ouvert à tous les vents
elle aidait tout ça était partie en asie
il ya un an s'est rendu compte qu'on
n'avait pas dit dre une animation pas
celle qu'on a laissé des gens mourir
parce que l'union européenne avait à 67
reprise demandé aux pays d'europe entre
2011 et 2018
selon un chef de
du parlement européen de quelqu'un
d'important au parlement européen de
privatiser des pans entiers de la santé
publique et de réduire les dépenses de
santé donc l'europe est extrêmement fait
beaucoup de mal
en fait au système de santé public elle
a été incapable de commander les vaccins
même sa stratégie parce que la stratégie
des vaccins l'autre spatiaux qu'elle
soit intelligente parce que les vaccins
est-ce qu'ils protégeront les gens des
variantes ou pas ça on n'en sait rien on
n'en est pas sûr du tout en tout cas ce
qu'on sait c'est que c'était la
stratégie de l'union européenne lors
c'est une stratégie complètement ratée
parce que l'europe est un attelage
encombrants peu manoeuvrant et qu'en
fait du coup elle à elle à vacciner
trois fois moins de gens que les
américains font moins que les droits des
outils qui a eu bien raison de sortir de
l'union européenne il est beaucoup plus
agile beaucoup plus véloce et pour finir
sur des vaccins
le français on va le voir distribuer la
parole pardonnez-moi philippe lauraire
vous aurez l'occasion de le dire
françois pour les métis un gala merkel
dit aussi évidemment qui a eu des ratés
à tel point que la chancelière allemande
ça ne lui ressemble pas vraiment à
lancer une forme d'avertissement et elle
dit en clair que si ça ne l'est pas plus
vite
elle prendrait les choses en main
comprendre on va agir seuls dans notre
coin nous les allemands comme l'a dit
philippe murray la santé c'est un
domaine qu'on ne peut pas mettre en
commun au sein de l'europe selon vous
ont scié juste mal pris il faut préciser
que la santé la politique de 100 parties
des politiques communautaires et donc
l'europe très opportunément a finalement
essayé de réagir suite à cette pandémie
pour trouver une solution pour avoir une
réaction commune dans un domaine où elle
n'est pas compétente a priori donc ça
c'est une nouveauté est ce que l'europe
a été à la hauteur non n'a pas été à la
hauteur ça c'est clair
par contre l'acte 1 de sa décision a été
une bonne décision
cette bonne décision ça a été de décider
de négocier ensemble groupe et des
contrats pour obtenir des vaccins et non
pas chacun séparément
on sait très bien ce que ça aurait pu
donner si chaque pays avait pris
séparément sa propre politique les
négociations au vaccin
il en aurait résulté peut-être pour
certains pays effectivement d'avoir été
un peu plus à la hauteur mais pour
d'autres pays d'être totalement
dépendants je suis pas persuadé que pour
la france elle soit sorti de manière
favoriser d'une situation où chacun aura
été dieu peu chacun pour soi dans la
mesure de la france n'a pas d'industrie
de vaccins et la france elle même avait
une très forte aux métis ans on se
souvient de la réticence de la
population française au vaccin donc on
risque et nous d'être encore un peu plus
en retard qu'on ne l'a été
alors c'est vrai l'europe n'a pas été la
hauteur mais elle a néanmoins réussi une
chose qui est essentiel qui est de
mettre en commun sa stratégie qui pour
l'instant n'est pas convaincante mais
qui pourrait le devenir demain parce que
la sphère n'est pas fini de les piles
des vignes ma mère que je suis au début
oui elle hésite parce que c'est vrai que
françois pour les bêtises marque un
point si je peux me permettre parce que
c'est vrai qu'en france on n'a pas de
vaccin mais non mais c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas de vaccin est bon qu'est ce
qu'on aurait fait de plus en gardons nos
stratégies de souveraineté sur l'art est
une stratégie industrielle
le problème c'est qu'on a à la fois
l'union européenne qui est un problème
et macron qui est robuste et qui veut
tout faire à travers l'union européenne
et il le dit tout le temps qui est un
problème parce que on à sanofi en à
pasteur et on aurait pu pousser ces
entreprises vraiment à faire un vaccin
mais vous savez qu'on avait un métier
dont il y avait un vaccin auprès de papa
c'est au moins qu'au royaume uni aux
états unis et il y avait bal neva
l'entreprise nantaise qui est très
intéressante qui a développé un vrai
accent scandale c'est pas débattre un cd
injection de code génétique notamment
les kaizer et bouderbal et si pour ça
que les gens sont pas là un des verts a
lancé une étude pour un vaccin inactivé
classique on aurait accepté beaucoup
plus facilement il y aurait aucun
problème aujourd'hui de confiance dans
ces vaccins tels qu'on a aujourd'hui
dorval même à l'union européenne ne l'a
pas aidé et en fait la france ne l'a pas
aidé au nom plus européistes magro l'a
pas aidé en fait c'est le royaume uni
qui agile qui pensent souveraine déchets
industriels qui pend stratégie
industrielle qui a donné de l'argent à
valdes et son accent et qui va avoir 60
millions de doses de vaccins inactivés
pas si ça se passe bien
cette année alors que l'union européenne
et même la france droite
vous rendez compte axa aurait permis de
donner de la confiance à la population
jusque c'est un vaccin inactivé
classique alors que les gens sont quand
même très réticent à s'injecter des
codes génétiques
alors que ce sont des vaccins je
rappelle enfin ce code génétique en
essai clinique et s'écrient les gens
s'énervent déco heureusement oui
françois pour les mathis allez allez on
est face à un problème d'urgence il faut
bien comprendre qu'on n'est pas dans une
solution pour prendre son temps pour
essayer de voir quelle est la meilleure
solution
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est prendre les
vaccins tels qu'ils existent et non pas
d'espérer des vaccins qui ne sont pas
encore sur le marché et les vaccins qui
existe actuellement et on a trois
peut-être la quatrième qui va arriver et
c'est les seuls sur lequel on peut
compter
qui aurait pu imaginer d'obtenir ce tri
arriver une augmentation très
substantielle notamment des vaccins
pfizer qui vont arriver en 12 beaucoup
plus importante dans l'est dans les
semaines qui viennent
grâce à une négociation au niveau
européen autre chose que fait-on par
rapport aux ratés du vaccin à seneca qui
n'a pas tenu ses promesses
seule l'europe est en mesure de faire
pression sur les entreprises sur
astrazeneca pour obliger cette
entreprise finalement à en respecter ses
engagements et donc voyez bien ses
partenaires france pas pour les matisse
mais vous voyez bien que c'est compliqué
vous nous dites il faut agir dans
l'urgence il faut prendre ce qu'il ya
mais on ne prend pas ce qui a regardé
les russes ont tendu la main aux
européens ça met des mois et des mois
alors je me doute qu'il ya du travail
mais enfin c'est quand même très lents
comme rythme pour aller certifier un
vaccin alors c'est pas vrai on prend
parce qu'il ya le temps que tout le
monde se mette d'accord ce sam et des
siècles en temps on prend ce qu'il y a
le problème c'est que les valses 1 ne
sont pas là les vaccins ne sont pas là
ils ça c'est pas le problème de l'ordre
c'est le problème des entreprises qui
n'arrivent pas à suivre le rythme mais
pourquoi c'est aussi long de l'année des
de valider un vaccin johnson & johnson a
été validée on attend toujours spoutnik
est en cours de validation ça m'est
vraiment longtemps non oui ou non vous
êtes bien qu il ya des garanties
actuellement l'europe à négocier ces
vaccins avec un minimum de garanties
faut savoir par exemple que pour le
vaccin russe qui a été accepté puisqu'il
est il a été ratifié donc il peut être
utilisé en europe le groupe n'était que
qu'arrive-t-il en cas de pépin
qu'arrive-t-il en cas d'effets
secondaires qui serait un petit peu
gênant pour un certain nombre de vaccins
la garantie juridique n'est pas là
l'europe a négocié une garantie
juridique qui permet finalement à toutes
les entreprises de s'engager à être
responsable juridiquement des
conséquences de tout à 6 ans sur le
vaccin
ça fait partie aussi des sécurité de
base que l'europe année conscience et
injustement ne submerge voulez vous
changer de nom justement la sécurité
juridique
selon le canard enchaîné les
commissaires européens ont tardé à
conclure des contrats avec les labos car
il voulait absolument avoir une clause d
protégeant personnellement de tout
procès sur les vaccins ce que les
anglais les américains et les israéliens
n'auraient pas demandé justement cette
sécurité juridique cette bureaucratie
est ce que c'est là que le bât blesse
c'était une sécurité juridique pour eux
tout seul parce que peut-être monsieur
poulet mathis a raison mais c'est la
première fois que j'entends dire que les
fabricants de vaccins sont responsables
en cas d'effets secondaires
j'ai lu exactement l'inversé depuis six
mois par tous donc que en fait c'étaient
les états qui seraient responsables
s'ils avaient des effets secondaires et
puis alors quelle sécurité
vous avez vu que l' agence européenne du
b
gamme en a réautorisé le vaccin
astrazeneca qui fait des thromboses
apparemment chez les jeunes et là on a
du coup la france la ré autorisé en
suivant comme un caniche l'agencé
européenne du médicament qui pourront
pourtant un repaire de lobbyistes et je
vais en parler tout de suite
c'est alors que l'autorité de santé
vient de dire la haute autorité de santé
française vient de dire en fait il ya
des vrais risques avec le astrazeneca
pour les jeunes pour les thromboses il y
a beaucoup de thrombose donc là on est
en net
il n'y a aucune sécurité juridique
l'agencé européenne du médicament est un
repère de lobbyistes de gens qui
viennent des lobbys pharmaceutiques mais
carrément ils sont engagés par les obus
de sable pharmaceutique plus tard il
devient directeur de l'agencé européenne
du médicament
ou alors il son directeur de l'agencé
européenne du médicament ils deviennent
lobbyistes la directrice générale
aujourd'hui et mercredi 1 du lobby de
big pharma
c'est sans doute pour ça qu'ils ont
autorisé des médicaments pas efficaces
contre le coc vide le rem des civils qui
vaut très cher de gilles ead les
anticorps monoclonaux qui ne sont
d'aucune preuve d'efficacité qui sont
très chers et de tester on ne les
connaît pas et elles ont refusé tous les
traitements pas cher le protocole raoult
l'azithromycine aussi qui marche très
bien sur les médecins qu'ils utilisent
et aussi bien sûr l'ivermectine qui est
selon l'om a sans danger utilisable à
grande échelle
tous les médecins qui l'utilisent dit
que c'est formidable c'est utilisé au
mexique en inde dans tout un pape et
dans une vingtaine de pays
et ça marche très très bien les études
montrent que c'est diviser par quatre la
mortalité
donc on est dans un repaire de
lobbyistes là il pourrait y avoir des
procès contre l'agencé européenne du
médicament pour les métis on en revient
à notre question initiale de débats ce
que l'europe peut survivre à cette
pandémie est qu'il y aura un avant et un
après qu'il nécessitera au moins une
sacrée réforme parce que les populations
risquent voilà on n'est pas au bout de
nos peines malheureusement les
populations à risque d'avoir quelques
rancunes ainsi elles ne sont pas
vaccinés que les états unis redémarre la
chine israël etc
j'avais les crises en europe c'est pas
la première
il y en a eu beaucoup et au général
l'europe se construit sur l'écrit c'est
ça qui est paradoxal c'est au travers
des crises que l'europe sait se
fortifier la dernière crise on l'a vu
avec le bris si tout le monde prédisait
un éclatement de l'europe
finalement le break site a eu pour
conséquence de ressouder entre les pays
d'europe
on l'a vu aussi au moment des crises
financières ou l'europe a su inventer
des méthodes et notamment des méthodes
qui permettent de d'emprunter de
l'argent de manière collective et non
pas de manière individuelle
on l'a vu dans l'histoire à 2,36 moment
au nom de l'élargissement ou il a fallu
trouver des solutions pour décider avec
plus grande efficacité où on a introduit
le vote à la majorité pour éviter une
solution une paralysie impossible
françois pour les vététistes la
population va suivre parce que si tout
le monde se met à voter pour des partis
très souverainiste et eurosceptique ça
va fragiliser l europe et le royaume uni
est bien parti oui mais l'europe est
toujours être fragilisé toujours est il
que l'europe
regardez ce qui se passe au niveau des
partis politiques y compris en france où
vous voyez les partis politiques comme
le rassemblement national qui était
d'une certaine manière très s'ouvrir à
une époque et on a vu madame marine le
pen qui aujourd'hui abandonne l'idée de
remettre en cause l'euro abandonne
l'idée de remettre en cause
l'appartenance à l'union européenne et
donc finalement les partis qui ont une
prétention un peu importante sur le plan
national
eux mêmes se rendre compte que aller
contre l'europe c'est aller contre la
nature aller contre l'évidence et donc
je crois simplement que les gens se
rendront compte et on le voit bien sur
le plan sanitaire sortir de cette crise
on n'en sortira pas seul pays isolé un
parent ne peuvent pas sentir seul on
doit être groupe et ça c'est clair
philippe merle le mot de la fin pour
l'économiste que vous êtes parce qu'à
aussi l'aspect économique on le vert
avec dave st-pierre dans quelques
instants
le retard pris par ce calendrier
vaccinal nous coûte apparemment à
l'europe 123 milliards d'euros
c'est ce qu'estime aujourd'hui
l'assureur crédit euler hermes pendant
ce temps effectivement les ayez à
d'autres pays qui vont redémarrer
et redémarrer plus fort plus vite ça va
beaucoup nous pénaliser nous autres
européens
oui deux choses qui vont nous pénaliser
vous avez raison la première chose c'est
que l'europe en fait à une très mauvaise
politique l'union européenne a une très
mauvaise politique et la zone euro à 7 %
de récession quand les états unis ont
deux fois moins de récession dont on est
le pays qui s'en sort déjà les pays s'en
sortent le moins du monde on est comme
d'habitude de toute manière le trou noir
de la présence mondiale
ça fait vingt ans que ça dure deuxième
chose le plan de relance européen et
cinq fois plus faible que le plan de
relance chinois et américains donc ça va
être catastrophique parce qu'on
redémarre à beaucoup moins vite à la
fois plus tard à cause des vaccins est
beaucoup moins vite parce que le plan de
relance est beaucoup trop petit beaucoup
trop saupoudré beaucoup trop étalé dans
le temps
il est mal fait comme tout ce que touche
l'union européenne et donc ça va mal se
passer
moi je finirai en vous disant est ce qu
est ce que l'europe survivre à la crise
j'espère que l'europe l'union européenne
ne survivra pas la crise la machine
bureaucratique européenne parce que
sinon c'est la france qui continuera un
déclin sans fin un déclin qui est là
depuis dix ou quinze ans et les gens le
voient monsieur les gens commencent à
plus pouvoir manger à leur faim
20% des français on peut rêver de
l'europe mais l'europe préparé des 30%
des gens qui ne se soignent plus parce
qu'ils n'ont pas assez d'argent 1
millions de pauvres en plus dans cette
crise est le problème grenat de toute
manière charles de gaulle l'avait très
bien dit la démocratie pour moi se
confond exactement avec la souveraineté
nationale
la machine bureaucratique européenne
piquant la souveraineté nationale la
démocratie est l'intérêt de la soupe du
vote populaire disparaît c'est toujours
les mêmes politiques économiques et même
politiques qui sont conduites et la
démocratie est malheureusement en train
de disparaître de plus en plus au
rendez-vous dans un an et on verra qui a
raison et bien rendez vous dans un an
rendez vous pris en tout cas deux
opinions différentes l intérêt des
face-à-face merci à tous les deux
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france reste avec nous dans quelques
instants justement nous parlerons du
plan de relance 1 les européens qui ne
voit toujours rien venir au contraire
des américains alors europe
en fait elle assez n'arrive-t-elle pas
trop tard par rapport aux états unis
exception tentera de répondre à cette
question et puis nous parlerons de
facebook avec un guide des règles de
modération qui a été révélée par le
quotidien britannique the guardian
[Musique]
l'agité pour tous ce que ça apporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à la dgre au poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire mais c'est pénalisant
pour l'enfant pour la famille on oublie
les parents qui sont responsables du
foyer est temps que les parents ne
maîtrise et ne parlent pas le français à
la maison bas ça va être difficile
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi qui ait des
candidats pas l'alternative on sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime
on parle de jay liste on parle de gens
qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est en irak sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours mon
adversaire même si je méprise totalement
son idéologie comme c'est le cas pour
séguiniste
et puis
bref vingt ans
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez 1400 $
pour chaque américain et ce n'est
peut-être qu'un début
alors qu'aux états unis des millions en
foyer commencent à recevoir leurs
chèques financé par un plan de relance
massif à 1900 milliards de dollars les
européens ne voit toujours rien venir
annonce elle est annoncée l'été dernier
le plan de lieu à 750 milliards d'euros
n'entrera en vigueur qu'à la fin de
cette année alors l'europe
en fait elle assez pour relancer son
économie n'arrive-t-elle pas trop tard
par rapport aux etats unis c'est l'objet
de l'édito échos ce soir bonsoir jacques
sapir comment expliquez vous cette
différence voir ce fossé entre le plan
de relance américain et son équivalent
européen
bonsoir c'est fanny et bien oui
effectivement c'est une différence qui
est très frappant est la comparaison
d'une certaine manière elle fait mal
entre le plan que vient de faire voter
joe biden qui est un plan à 1900
milliards de dollars c'est à dire à peu
près 1600 milliards d'euros et le plan
de 750 milliards d'euros qui a été
décidé l'année dernière et qui n'est
toujours pas appliqué par l'union
européenne ajoutons à cela le fait que
évidemment le plan américain n'est pas
le premier n'est pas le seul plan il ya
eu d'autres plans avant qui ont été
faits par donald trump et ça vient
évidemment s'ajouter à toutes ces
différences alors il faut quand même
dire une chose c'est que le plan
européen vient s'ajouter quant à lui à
des différents plans nationaux parce que
les états ont fait une réponse nationale
en particules réponses budgétaires
nationales et qui n'est pas négligeable
mais néanmoins quand on regarde
l'ensemble des chiques entre garde le
total des chiffres
eh bien oui il y a une très forte
différence entre ce qui sera dépensé aux
états unis et ceux qui sera dépensé dans
les pays de l'union européenne alors
jacquin qui at-il exactement dans ce
plan américain alors
ce plan dont de 1900 milliards ou de
1600 milliards d'euros si on le calcule
en euros mais il comprend plusieurs
choses on a tout d'abord des dz des
aides qui sont versées à chaque
américain
on a après le paiement d'une allocation
supplémentaire pour les américains qui
sont au chômage
on a ensuite des déductions fiscales des
crédits d'impôts qui sont portés à 3000
$ pour les pour chaque enfant entre 6 et
17 ans et pour les enfants en dessous de
6 ans ces mêmes 3600 dollars et puis on
a différentes autres aides des aides aux
collectivités locales et des aides en
particulier pour la réouverture des
écoles
bon tout ceci fait une masse d'argent
considérables on l'a dit un ça va faire
1900 milliards de dollars
ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
relève plutôt du soutien immédiat à
l'économie et il faut dire que les
ménages américains
on avait vraiment besoin parce que la
protection sociale aux états unis il
faut toujours s'en souvenir
elle n'est pas du tout au niveau de ce
qui existe en france en allemagne en
belgique en italie ou aux pays bas
donc c'est essentiellement un plan de
soutien de l'économie
et comment se situent les états unis par
rapport aux autres grands pays dans le
monde
alors je crois que c'est surtout sur
cette comparaison que l'on va toucher la
différence et je veux dire cesser ces
comparaisons là qui nous fait mal quand
on le regarde pourquoi et bien parce
qu'on va voir qu'en termes de mesures
budgétaires de contributions budgétaires
au soutien à l'économie les etats unis
ils sont quasiment à 26%
l'union européenne est à moins de 5%
la france est autour de 7% l'allemagne
qui est l'un des pays qui en a le plus
fait est à 11%
donc on est aujourd'hui confronté à
quelque chose qui est assez étonnant
c'est que ce sont les deux pays qui ont
la réputation d'être les plus libéraux
en économie
la grande-bretagne et les etats-unis
qui en ont fait largement plus en terme
de pib si vous venez en termes de
dépenses budgétaires par rapport au pib
que les pays européens qui ont plutôt la
réputation d'être beaucoup plus sociaux
démocrates ou d'avoir développé un état
providence beaucoup plus fort même la
grande bretagne par exemple elle est au
dessus de 16% et on voit que ça
d'une certaine manière ça ridiculise un
petit peu les chiffres qui sont faits
dans l'union européenne en france en
italie et encore plus en espagne alors
cela veut dire finalement que les états
unis ont été plus touché par la pandémie
que l'union européenne vient non non et
c'est ça qui est aussi extrêmement
étonnant si vous voulez on sait que tous
les pays développés ont connu une
récession de l'ordre de 5% un petit peu
moins de 5% et là dessus on voit que la
récession aux états unis elle a été
relativement faible comparée à la zone
euro
nous avons une rose et une récession
globalement en termes de zone euro qui a
été plus de deux fois supérieur à moins
7,2 pour cent contre -3 1% pour les
états unis et en plus en france on est à
moins 8,3 en italie on est à moins 9 6%
bon pourquoi est ce que les états unis
ont d'une certaine manière moins
souffert des conséquences économiques de
la pandémie
mais il ya plusieurs raisons à cela la
raison principale étant quand même la
taille du pays et le fait que jamais les
états unis n'ont été globalement fermé
si vous voulez on a eu on a toujours des
situations de confinement dans certains
états sur certaines agglomérations par
exemple new york qui est encore
aujourd'hui très largement confiné mais
à côté de ça vous avez d'autres états où
on travaille normalement
donc cela a quand même beaucoup
contribué à réduire
je dirais le choc économique de la
pandémie jacques on en vient maintenant
aux plans de relance européens dont on
parlait ou est il donc passé
et oui ma soeur stéphanie que voyez-vous
venir
vous connaissez la formule alors il faut
se rappeler une chose ce plan il a été
décidé en juillet 2020 et il a été
ratifié en décembre 2020 on nous annonce
aujourd'hui au mieux qu'il rentrerait en
action cet été c'est à dire avec douze
mois de retard par rapport à la décision
est en réalité on s'attend plutôt à ce
qu'ils rentrent en action à la fin de
l'automne au début de l'hiver donc entre
15 et 18 mois après la décision
alors pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
pris un tel retard alors d'abord il ya
des choses qui sont liées aux procédures
européennes c'est un plan de l'union
européenne
et ça veut donc dire que tous les pays
de l'union européenne doivent voter les
mesures du plan et ça ça va prendre du
temps parce qu'il ya toute une série de
pays qui ont des désaccords et où il va
falloir d'une certaine manière
convaincre les oppositions ça c'est un
premier point deuxième point et de la
commission européenne qui en est
responsable parce que la commission
européenne elle demande à regarder très
précisément ce qu'elle va financer et si
ce que les pays ont décidé de financer
ne correspond pas aux priorités de la
commission européenne elle refuse en
tous les cas elle provoque un mécanisme
si vous voulez on rediscute avec les
gouvernements
tout ceci prend du temps et puis il ya
une troisième raison une raison qui peut
être non dit et bien c'est le fait que
il va y avoir des élections à la fin de
l'année en allemagne aura nous savons
tous des élections très importante en
france les élections présidentielles
l'année prochaine peut-être que le
gouvernement français comme le
gouvernement allemand cherche à retarder
l'entrée en action de ce plan de manière
à pouvoir dire si vous voulez au moment
des élections
voilà l'argent européen vient vous voyez
c'est l'union
européenne qui nous protège bon ajoutons
à cela une chose c'est que ces 750
milliards d'euros ils doivent être
dépensés au mieux sur deux ans et plus
de manière plus raisonnable sur quatre
ans donc on n'est pas du tout au niveau
du plan de relance américain
mais les montants de ces plans européens
et américains jacques sont ils
comparables finalement non non
absolument pas alors rappelons l'union
européenne c'est 457 millions
d'habitants pour ces 457 millions
d'habitants nous avons donc 750
milliards d'euros ça nous fait à peu
près 1000 1600 euros par habitant aux
états unis nous avons 1600 milliards
pour 328 millions d'habitants est alors
si on rapporte évidemment à l'ensemble
des mesures de soutien budgétaire
la différence est encore plus en notre
défaveur
les etats-unis ont dépensé depuis mars
2020 c'est-à-dire sur un an grosso modo
maintenant sur 13 mois
ils ont dépensé 14 1140 euros par
habitant alors que nous n'avons dépenses
et nous que en france que 2500 70 euros
les allemands qu'ils 33 l'italie 1737 la
belgique 3000 euros donc il y a là aussi
une énorme différence alors bien sûr on
dira les pays européens ont plus recouru
à des mesures d'ordre monétaire
mais ces mesures d'ordre monétaire c'est
la banque centrale européenne
en réalité qui les a rendues possibles
et puis qu'est ce qu'elles aboutissent à
quoi aboutit ce tout simplement à
accroître l'endettement l'endettement
des entreprises d'endettement des
ménages
c'est pas du tout une bonne solution et
on voit là que les états unis ils ont
pris un temps d'avancé considérable par
rapport à ce que l'on fait en europe
et justement quelles conséquences alors
la conséquence on le voit déjà aux états
unis c'est que l'économie
américaine elle redémarre même si la
pandémie est très loin d'être réglée aux
états unis si vous voulez tout le monde
le sait tout le monde sait qu'il ya
toujours d'énormes problèmes sanitaires
bien sûr les états unis sont aussi très
en avance sur nous sur la vaccination
lyall là non plus il n'y a pas photo
comme comme on dit mais globalement
l'économie redémarre alors ça se voit
sur différents chiffres ça se voit en
particulier sur les dépenses de
construction qui ont littéralement bondi
qui ont explosé d'ailleurs ça pose
aujourd'hui des problèmes en europe et
en france ça fait monter le prix de tous
les matériaux de construction et du bois
pourquoi parce que la demande
aujourd'hui en bois de construction des
états unis est telle qu'elle est en
train de saturer le marché
et puis il ya d'autres chiffres qui sont
extrêmement intéressants et qui montre
que très probablement les états unis ne
revint mais est allé retrouveront leurs
niveaux de production d'avant la crise
sanitaire vers la fin de cette année
voir la fin de l'automne pour ce qui est
de l'union européenne et en admettant
que la campagne vaccinale se passe comme
prévu ce qui vous le savez est loin
d'être gagné et bien ce serait plutôt à
la fin 2022
donc là encore on voit bien que l'union
européenne a pris un an de retard sur
les etats-unis l'union européenne a pu
dire tout ce qu'elle voulait sur la
mauvaise politique de tram sur la
politique des américains même de joe
biden qui n'étaient pas adéquates face à
la pandémie
la réalité est des lames nous avons pris
un an de retard dans notre réponse face
à la crise
et ça ça va jouer parce qu'on voit bien
que l'europe elle est en train de
décrocher
elle décroche et ça je vous l'avais déjà
dit par rapport à la chine et à l'asie
du sud-est c'était évident mais ce qui
est nouveau aujourd'hui
est ce que l'on voit de plus en plus
dans les chiffres économiques c'est
qu'elle décroche aussi très nettement
par rapport aux états unis alors jacques
que faudrait-il faire bien ce que l'on
voit c'est que aujourd'hui il faut d'une
certaine manière de la flexibilité il
faut peut-être mettre de côté ce cadre
de l'union européenne qui par sa
bureaucratie par les compromis qui sont
nécessaires au sein des 27 pays qui nous
tire en arrière qui est en train de
plomber littéralement l'économie
l'économie de la france mais aussi
globalement l'économie des pays de
l'union européenne il est temps et ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose dont on
est tous en train de prendre conscience
et qui jouera évidemment un rôle
extrêmement important lors de la
prochaine élection présidentielle
il est temps de renationaliser nos
politiques économiques
on voit bien que l'union européenne
n'est pas capable de fait ce pourquoi
elle a été créée et merci jacques pour
cet éclairage qui est le vôtre merci à
vous mais la semaine prochaine
les patrons de facebook twitter et
google auditionné cet après midi par les
parlementaires américains pour répondre
aux élus sur le problème de la
désinformation les mesures des réseaux
sociaux contre l'effet cno sont jugées
insuffisantes par de nombreux élus et
organisations de la société civile
facebook dans le guide des règles de
modération a été révélée par le
quotidien britannique the guardian
une fuite leur a donné accès à 300 pas
distribué en interne pour définir ce qui
est autorisé ou non sur le réseau social
est des comptines parfois surprenantes
que nous détaille thomas bonnin vu
l'ambiance actuellement sur les réseaux
sociaux ne dit pas non un petit guide
pratique alors quand des journalistes du
guardian dévoile le contenu de 300 pages
de ce qui est présenté comme un guide à
usage interne pour les salariés de
facebook on le lit attentivement
dans cet article on apprend par exemple
quelle serait la politique en vigueur en
ce qui concerne les appels à la violence
ainsi
ces publications pourrait être toléré
lorsqu'elles concernent des
personnalités publiques
s'il s'agit d'une formulation figurative
et si la personnalité en question n'est
pas directement tagué sur la publication
alors cette dernière ne serait pas
supprimé nous pensons qu'il est
important d'autoriser des débats
critiques concernant des politiques et
d'autres personnes publiques mais cela
ne signifie pas que nous autorisons les
gens à les harceler sur nos applications
reste que la définition par facebook
d'une personnalité publique mais pas
très clair et qu'il reste délicat de
mesurer l'impact de milliers de
publications sur une personne autre
aspect abordé dans ce guide interne
celui du soutien des organisations
interdites comme par exemple les groupes
terroristes facebook interdit la
justification d'actions violentes mais
autoriserait des messages jugés comme
factuel l'exemple utilisé dans le guide
est le suivant la phrase l'ira a été
poussé à la violence par les pratiques
brutales du gouvernement britannique en
irlande serait autorisée tandis que
l'ira avait raison d'utiliser la
violence pour combattre les pratiques
brutales du gouvernement britannique au
cours du 20e siècle serait interdite
des subtilités qui vont jusqu'à modéré
lusage des emoji dans réaction des
publications qui concerne des
organisations interdites
ce guide de 300 pages servirait de
support aux modérateurs de facebook et
malgré ces révélations du guardian la
politique de modération du réseau social
reste opaque
déjà parce que ce guide n'avait pas
vocation à être publié officiellement
pour éviter de donner aux utilisateurs
malveillants les clés pour contourner
les règles en vigueur
d'autre part car le service externalisé
de modération ne parvient pas à régler
toutes les situations outre les
accusations récurrentes de censure
certains critiquent les agissements de
facebook en matière de modération
justement cette semaine les ong
reporters sans frontières a déposé une
plainte en france contre le géant
américain pour pratiques commerciales
trompeuses facebook en one size seysses
d'un côté facebook dit qu'il s'engage
contre la circulation des discours de
haine ou de fausses d'information est en
réalité les théories du complot les
discours haineux circulent massivement
sur le réseau social et speech
à circuler heated massive les andes aux
fenêtres eu l' équilibre entre lutte
contre les discours de haine et défense
de la liberté d'expression est toujours
difficile à trouver mais en conservant
l'opacité sur ces méthodes et en s'étant
fait épingler pour des mesures motivé
par ses propres intérêts économiques et
idéologiques facebook peine à convaincre
ses prêts de 3 milliards d'utilisateurs
jadis plateforme adulée pour sa
nouveauté facebook est désormais de plus
en plus critiqué la régulation
arbitraire des contenus explique en
partie une forme de désintérêt beaucoup
ont compris que le réseau social est à
utiliser avec modération
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
fabrice epelboin spécialiste des médias
professeur à sciences po bonsoir fabrice
au fn - merci d'être avec nous ce qui
frappe quand on écoute ce sujet c'est
cette opacité autour de la politique de
facebook de modération précisément
comment l'expliquer il faut bien
comprendre que ces documents que s'est
procuré le guardian ce n'est pas la
première fois que ce type de document
fuite
ces destinées à des armes et de
modérateur qui vont appliquer de façon
extrêmement mécanique avec aucune forme
de réflexion aucune porte de jugement un
ensemble de règles de façon à modérer
une quantité infinie de contenu on n'est
pas du tout dans une logique de justice
avec un débat contradictoire un juge qui
réfléchit à la sanction qui va prendre
c'est même exactement l'inversé et c'est
l'avenir de la gouvernance de la liberté
d'expression dans tout un tas de pays
dont la france c'est précisément ce que
la loi via voulait faire confier la
régulation de la liberté d'expression à
les acteurs tels que facebook
on voit l'envers du décor c'est toujours
très intéressant de devoir cette
alternative complète à la justice que
les démocraties ont l'habitude de
côtoyer et si l'occasion de vraiment se
demander si c'est vers là qu'on peut
aller c'est surtout que quand on
décortique un petit peu ce texte texte
on se rend compte qu'il ya des
subtilités qui confine à la turbie
comment les appliquer elles sont confiné
à l'absurde mais il faut aussi bien
comprendre que c'est un texte qui
s'applique à tout un tas de pays tout un
tas de culture tout un tas de
juridictions différentes
et qui essaye de faire quelque chose qui
va conduire à à peu près tout le monde
est de toute évidence ça ne fonctionne
pas mais facebook ne peut pas se
permettre n'a pas les moyens de faire du
local ne peut vraiment pas appliquer la
loi localement ça n'est pas une instance
de justice
il ne peut pas se permettre de dépenser
ce que représente une véritable justice
et donc il va sous traiter à des
entreprises qui ne sont pas facebook et
donc avec une pression financière
spectaculaire sur le roman sur
l'efficacité de cette modération de
façon à se débarrasser des problèmes et
en optimiser le coût forcément le
résultat est très discutable
alors il ya un chapitre aussi sur les
causes politiques controversées voire
illégales dans certains pays c'est fait
l'objet d'un long développement dans ce
guide
je cite avec grail l'interdisent la
justification d'actions violentes par le
fait qu'une cause soient légitimement
fin là on apprend quelque chose de
délicat qui décide que c'est légitime
on est extrêmement c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'extrêmement délicat
en temps normal à l'époque du printemps
arabe si ces règles avaient été en
application le printemps arabe n'aurait
peut-être pas démarré en tout cas pas de
la façon dont il a démarré sur facebook
il ya énormément de remous sociaux qui
peuvent être tués dans l'oeuf par ce
type de règles et on imagine malgré tout
que en termes de stabilité sociale c'est
quelque chose que beaucoup d'états ont
demandé à facebook a commencé par l'état
américain
oui avec une illustration j'allais y
venir avec donald trump qui a été assez
mal traités par ce réseau social et les
autres d'ailleurs il a été maltraité
mais il a été aussi porté aux nues
étaient aussi croit à la fertonne de
génétique à c'est en grande partie avec
facebook il a été élu donc ça s'est mal
terminée c'est une belle histoire
d'amour qui s'est très mal terminé
donald trump va rebondir dans d'autres
réseaux sociaux n'ont pas tort oui oui
justement il a annoncé cette semaine
qu'il lancerait sa propre plateforme les
géants du web doivent s'en inquiéter on
va voir ça va être un épisode
intéressant parce que facebook et
laisser les réseaux sociaux d'une façon
générale ne sont pas en odeur de
sainteté le grand public a fini par
comprendre que tout ça a été extrêmement
dangereux et que tout ça pouvait avoir
un impact profond sur les sociétés et
les abîmes et de façon vraiment
significative est-ce que donald trump va
réussir à amener vers lui énormément de
gens aient constitué une autre bulle un
autre média social ça va être très
intéressant à observer et si c'est le
cas ça sera quelque chose de redoutables
peut-on craindre à l'avenir des réseaux
sociaux définis justement qu'en fonction
des courants politiques
c'est déjà quelque part en partie le cas
les réseaux sociaux enferme les gens
dans des des formes de bulles des silos
informationnel qui sont très souvent un
connoté politiquement le fait que yoichi
en et plusieurs ne change finalement pas
grand chose sur ces réseaux sociaux
la plupart d'entre nous savons faire
mais dans des bulles qui sont très
homogènes politiquement parlant ce qui
donne effectivement cette sp2 de toute
puissance où les gens sont persuadés
d'avoir raison parce qu'effectivement
ils sont au milieu de gens qui ont une
très grande homogénéité de penser et à
force de ne voir que des gens qui
pensons qu'ils pensent de la même façon
que nous on a l'impression d'avoir la
vérité universelle et surtout dans une
vaste majorité y compris si on est un
tout petit groupe minoritaire
c'est l'un des effets de ces douze
informationnelle et depuis très
longtemps
les réseaux sociaux sont très connotées
politiquement et justement fabrice
epelboin comment favoriser une forme de
mixité dans les opinions restent eux
mans c'est compliqué parce que c'est
visiblement contradictoire avec les
modèles économiques de ces plateformes
donc il faudrait déjà se trouver un
autre modèle économique un modèle
économique qui ne favorise pas le clash
la confrontation à un modèle économique
qui ferait que les gens s'accorderait
sur d'autres logiques
j'ai peur que le problème ne viennent
pas tant des plateformes le problème
vient de la rencontre entre ces
algorithmes sociaux qui nous envahissent
équipe qui régule de plus en plus notre
vie sociale surtout en période de
confinement et puis la société telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui en france et
ailleurs et la problématique vraiment
est plutôt à regarder du côté des
sociétés
on est en se pendant dans un société qui
pour reprendre l'analyse de jérôme
fourquet est en train de se réaliser
avec des petits îlots fait de gens qui
pensent de la même façon qui s'isole et
qui reste dans un entre soi
le problème et social l'algorithme fait
que révéler tout ça merci beaucoup
fabrice et appelle points
des médias professeur à sciences po
d'avoir été avec nous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
la situation sanitaire nièvre au néo
bourgeoise les 16 départements soumis
aux mesures de freinage renforcé annonce
d'olivier véran tout à l'heure qui
évoque une situation préoccupante dans
le pays et puis nous irons en israël
l'israël qui fait un pas de plus vers la
liberté la moitié de la population a
reçu deux doses de vaccin teaser biotech
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent la haine en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême un
musée de madonna tous les témoins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même ce
sont les trafiquants de drogue
d'une certaine façon qui sont peut-être
les meilleurs adeptes de la
mondialisation c'est à dire que ils ont
inventé les routes de la drogue bien
avant que les entreprises ne découvrent
les bienfaits de la mondialisation on ne
visualise pas à quel point ça peut être
compliqué de se retrouver avec dans son
garage une montagne de billets de banque
comme ça il faut en faire quelque chose
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
comment l'économie chinoise at elle
résisté à la pandémie de corona des
russes l' empire du milieu est il le
grand gagnant de cette crise la chine
est encore lucide du monde vu que ses
clients sont en récession tous les
produits chinois ne sont pas vendus
consommation les sikhs en chine depuis
de la crise et la relance de 2007-2008 a
pris le pas sur les autres facteurs de
croissance que la chine soit la première
à repartir c'est une certitude
c'est les premiers à avoir maîtrisé la
pandémie ils ont préféré mettre le
paquet sur la règle du virus et
retrouver des conditions normales
d'activité économique plutôt que sur des
relances monétaire ou de l'endettement
de départ l'espèce de jeu pouvoir pour
la suprématie mondiale la chine à
quelques mètres d'avancé sur ses
poursuivants
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fall de l'apli pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont l'un des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
non
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous les libéraux uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose dignité
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre pensait
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 25 mars la nièvre le rhône l'aube
rejoignent la liste des départements en
mesure de freinage renforcé conférence
de presse tout à l'heure d'olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé qui
évoque une situation préoccupante
surtout en ile-de-france dans les hauts
de france et en paca est toujours deux
objectifs avoir réalisé une injection de
vaccin d'imminentes français à la
mi-avril et conserver les écoles
ouvertes
on y ferait un pas de plus vers la
liberté la moitié de la population a
reçu deux doses de vaccin 13h bio n tech
sorte ni restaurants salles de sport
sont désormais accessibles aux
détenteurs du passeport vert grâce à
cette vaccination de masse l'épidémie
continue de reculer dans le pays
seuls quatre cent soixante dix nouveaux
cas ont été enregistrés à ce jour
lyon clermont ferrand les agriculteurs
en colère ont défilé opération escargot
fumier déversé tracteurs en ville
la loi et gally mais le projet de la
réforme de la pac
un rapport préconise et de rendre
obligatoire à une signature d'un contrat
pluriannuel entre agriculteurs et
industriels qui va transformer ces
produits et puis en libye un
gouvernement d'union nationale qui
oeuvrent pour clore dix ans de guerre
dans le pays il appelle au retrait
immédiat des forces étrangères tout
comme les chefs de la diplomatie
française allemande et italienne en
visite à tripoli
dans un geste européen d'unités de
soutien face à ses récents progrès
politiques les élections nationales
seront lieu le 24 décembre
[Musique]
et avoir de développer ses titres
direction tout de suite place de la
république à paris où des tentes de
migrants ont été montés à l'initiative
de plusieurs collectifs qui sont
présents près de quatre mois après une
première opération on retrouve ramona
hamoud
sur place tout à l'heure en attendant on
va revenir sur cette crise sanitaire
restrictions jours lady en titre
renforcer dans le département de l'aube
de la nièvre et du rhône verdict de la
conférence de presse hebdomadaire
d'olivier vers ans ils viennent
s'ajouter à la liste des 16 départements
déjà confiné ont fait le point avec
grégoire dossier
le sujet de grégoire douce et donc
quelques instants qui nous résume donc
cette conférence de presse d'olivier et
veyran avec plusieurs départements trois
départements de plus sans restriction la
nièvre et le rhône rejoignent les 16
départements placés précédemment en
confinement par l'exécutif
l'annnonce du ministre de la santé était
pressenti depuis plusieurs heures à
compter de ce vendredi minuit et pour
quatre semaines donc dans ces trois
départements le couvre feu continue de
s'appliquer
de 19 heures à 6 heures les
rassemblements en extérieur ne doivent
pas dépasser six personnes les
déplacements sont autorisés de 6 heures
à 19 heures lorsque c'est dans un rayon
inférieur à 10 km sans attestation sans
limitation de durée
on vous demande d'avoir sur vous un
justificatif de domicile comme une pièce
d'identité entre 6 heures et 19 heures
si vous dépassez 10 km depuis votre
domicile mais également de 19h à 6h
cette fois ci quelle que soit la
distance
vous devrez avoir une attestation
dérogatoire pas de confinement
généralisée pour l'instant malgré des
indicateurs épidémique qui ne
s'infléchit ce pas le gouvernement se
donne une dizaine de jours pour évaluer
l'efficacité des mesures en place
olivier ferrand qui explique également
qu'en raison des variants et de la
vaccination déjà avancé des seniors les
patients en réanimation sont de plus en
plus jeunes quant aux écoles
elle reste ouverte et ne seront fermées
qu'en dernier recours mais s'apprête à
voir leur protocole sanitaire une
nouvelle fois renforcé
pourquoi est-ce que nous maintenons les
écoles ouvertes la fermeture des écoles
c'est une décision de dernier recours
que nous voulons à tout prix éviter
parce que nous savons qu'elle a des
conséquences très lourdes sur le
développement des enfants et sur le
quotidien des parents nous ne nions pas
que le virus peut aussi se transmettre à
l'école puis de l'école vers les
familles c'est pourquoi avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
nous travaillerons à des protocoles
sanitaires renforcés en sus de ceux qui
sont déjà mises en place dans les
établissements scolaires l'éducation
fait donc toujours partie des priorités
affichées par les autorités depuis le
très strict premier confinement les
écoles n'ont plus fait l'objet d'une
fermeture généralisée très fort en
parler nous sommes avec pierre tattevin
épidémiologie
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses au chu de rennes bonsoir
pierre cette zone merci d'être avec nous
on l'a entendu trois au département en
restriction renforcé aujourd'hui en
france quelle est la situation chez vous
à rennes c'est une situation tendue
depuis deux mois déjà on n'est jamais
vraiment descendu de la deuxième vague
mais c'est pas si terrible que dans
d'autres parties de la france donc on
fait pas partie des départements confiné
pour l'instant tant mieux pour vous on
vous souhaite que ça dure
comment vous gérez la situation dans vos
hôpitaux les choses se passent plutôt
sereinement pour le moment on essaye de
rester serein mais je sais pas si le mot
est pas un peu fort quand même en tout
cas on a le temps d'anticiper et de
pouvoir avoir un deux jours d'avant sur
les capacités d'accueil des patients
donc on refuse personne on n'a ni la
place si on arrive à accueillir tous les
patients qui ont besoin
comment vous expliquer cette situation
plutôt calme entre guillemets dans votre
région
il ya peut-être plus d'espacé gestes
barrières sont sont mieux respectés
on n'a pas d'explication très
convaincante on a la chance de pas avoir
de grandes métropoles ça c'est sûr que
ça doit pouvoir nous aider pas de zones
de concentration de population très
importante
on a peut-être aussi une population qui
écoutent mieux les gestes barrière n'a
aucune preuve pour dire ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on aime bien dire et puis on a
aussi la chance de ne pas avoir deux
pays frontaliers
ce qui fait qu'on n'a pas été touché
comme par exemple italie a été très
touchée ça a certainement eu un impact
sur des les départements limitrophes me
sagaut n'a pas puisque autour de nous
c'est la mer finalement bel et bien de
la chance en tout cas on va quitter la
bretagne 1 et vous demander votre
expertise de médecins sur le reste du
pays quand vous entendez voilà qu'il ya
des régions très tendue a notamment
l'ile-de-france et que la fermeture des
récoles finalement reste un tout dernier
recours selon la sémantique du porte
parole du gouvernement qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous vous dites qu'il ya
une forme d'irresponsabilité ou que
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
non non pas du tout quand on a eu la
premier les premiers confinement là on
n'avait pas beaucoup d'informations et
on avait la suspicion que les enfants
puissent jouer vraiment un rôle
important dans la transmission de
l'épidémie
ensuite on a eu des données solides qui
ont montré que leur rôle est mineur dans
la circulation du virus ils sont assez
peu contaminateur ils peuvent l'être
sont bien sûr mais beaucoup moins que
les adultes par exemple est ce qui fait
que le raisonnement entre le risque
qu'on prend à fermer des écoles sur la
santé des enfants y compris la santé
mentale et le bénéfice à la ferme et
fait vraiment plutôt penché comme comme
ça a été dit par le ministre je pense
que c'est le dernier recours il ya
sûrement d'autres choses qu'il faut
arrêter avant de fermer les écoles
peut-être les transports en commun
peut-être tout d'autres pans de
l'activité mais je pense c'est vraiment
bien d'avoir protégé les écoles temps
compte alors pourtant les choses
semblent avoir changé
rien n'est jamais vraiment très clair
dans cette pandémie au début vous l'avez
rappelé on nous disait nos enfants ne
sont pas très contaminateur on semble
nous dire un petit peu le contraire
maintenant avec ces variants est-ce
toujours le cas les enfants sont pas des
dangers pour les adultes compte avant
leurs familles et les enseignants
ce qu'on a vu sur les dernières semaines
c'est qu'effectivement l'âge moyen des
patients touchés à abaisser un petit peu
mais il ya plusieurs phénomènes là
dedans il est possible que le variant
britannique qui est maintenant largement
dominant en france
ce soit un peu plus transmissibles chez
des sujets jeunes et puis on a aussi le
fait d'avoir vraiment bien protégé les
sujets âgés là c'est vrai qu'on commence
à voir des couverture vaccinale chez les
plus de 75 ans qui ont beaucoup diminué
le risque dans ces populations
donc tout ça explique les incidences
comme on voit bien là sur votre courbe a
plutôt tendance à augmenter chez les
enfants mais ça reste probablement pas
des grandes sources de contamination des
autres le plus souvent quand
l'enfant quand il ya une épidémie dans
une famille ça vient de l'adulte plutôt
que de lancer aujourd'hui comment vous
expliquer cette baisse dans la moyenne
d'âge en termes de réanimation c'est la
vaccination qui qui explique cette
donnée ça doit jouer un rôle parce qu'on
a vraiment beaucoup mieux patiné on voit
que l'incidence a baissé chez les plus
de 65 ans les l'incidence de l'aco vite
donc je c'est sûr qu'on a réussi à
protéger les plus âgés en priorité comme
c'était prévu mais il ya peut-être aussi
l'impact de ce variant britannique on
connaît encore pas très bien et qui a
peut-être tendance à pousser un peu plus
les sujets jeunes en réanimation saura
bientôt on
c'est une possibilité parce qu'il est
encore possible d'accéder la vaccination
sans re confiné
car il ya malheureusement un beau
décalage je ne sais pas honnêtement il
faut surveiller de très près il faudra
pas ça ne fera rien s'interdire un
finalement mais on quand on voit les
pays qu'ont pu vacciner plus vite et de
manière plus massive on voit que à un
moment la vaccination fini par inverser
des courbes et on espère que ça va
arriver rapidement sans qu'on ait besoin
de re confiner la france alors on a eu
un nouveau collègue un professeur annan
ce matin qu'on a entendu qui nous a pas
fait passer une bonne journée un pas de
retour à la normale avant la fin de la
décennie un bon dit il a quand on sait
qu'on est en 2021 ça plombe un petit peu
le le moral ce professeur qui les lie
lannan qui ne voient pas de porte de
sortie
c'est pas un peu pessimiste tout de même
lire et animateur lui c'est quelqu'un
qui connaît beaucoup de choses donc on
va pas dire le contraire mais il y voit
ce qu'on voit de pire en ce moment
depuis quelques semaines c'est les
réanimations qui ont le moment les plus
difficiles donc ça doit forcer un peu
son pessimisme
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle le retour à
la normale mais non effectivement il n'y
aura pas de retour à la normale
probablement pas en 2021 par exemple
mais on va se rapprocher de la normale
et moi qui suis plus optimiste j'ai
tendance à penser que partir du moment
où on aura matinée plus de la moitié de
la population donc on peut penser que ça
arrivera un moment de l'été on va voir
quand même beaucoup moins de circulation
du virus et on pourra progressivement
levé les barrières sur les restaurants
sur les masques etc
merci pierre tattevin épidémiologistes
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses au chu de rennes d'avoir
été avec nous on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure des tentes de migrants était
monté à l'initiative de plusieurs
collectifs qui sont présents place de la
république à paris près de quatre mois
après une première opération similaire
qui avait vu les forces de l'ordre
d'intervenir mona hamou dès lors vous
êtes en direct sur place la situation à
celle évolué depuis tout à l'heure la
situation est toujours la même plusieurs
centaines de migrants se sont installés
sur cette place de la république
regardez juste derrière moi sur les
images de lui qu'à toi une mère une mère
de plusieurs tentes sont installées ici
depuis environ 18h30 à l'appel de
plusieurs associations plusieurs
collectifs qui espère pouvoir passer la
nuit ici on se souvient à l'épisode 2
novembre 2020 avec une évacuation très
musclée de la part des forces de l'ordre
et bien ce soir c'est différent
leur présence est très discrète plutôt
timide en tout cas si on veut comparer
l'année dernière plusieurs profils sont
ici c'est sur cette place de la
république des femmes des enfants des
hommes sont présents ici je suis
d'ailleurs avec madame karamoko merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce soir sur
arte france
dites nous à quelle est votre situation
aujourd'hui
tout d'abord mais c'est madame ma
situation a que des pays
et quelques mois je suis à la rue donc
comme vous le constatez avec
l'association et oupia aujourd'hui ils
n'ont pas de solution pour nous ils
disent que nous tous on doit venir dont
milad donc on est là aujourd'hui vous
avez une petite fille comment est ce que
vous faites au quotidien ou est-ce que
vous dormez
[Musique]
1 on a pas d'endroit particuliers
souvent d'osh et déjà des bonnes
volontés et mais souvent on doit dans
les paroisses c'est ça et aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez qu'est ce que vous demandez
pour ceux qui on demande
à l'état c'est pour que nos situations
soient un peu sais pas comment les 10 on
veut une vie normale comme les autres
une vie stable ce qui enlevait est-ce
que c'est plus difficile avec le coup
vide 8,3 difficile parce que je vous
n'avez pas papier vous ne travaillez pas
comment on peut donc s est très très
difficile pour moi
vous êtes arrivé en quelle année en
france en 2018 mais votre situation ce
que vous avez pu avoir des papiers vous
avez été débouté et non j'ai pas j'ai
pas eu des papiers j'ai été dégoûté
merci beaucoup pour ce témoignage de
madame car beaucoup vous l'avez entendu
des teams ce témoignage de ces dames
mais ce n'est pas la seule j'ai pu
parler notamment à d'autres fans qui
étaient présentes ici avec leurs enfants
avec leurs maris et cette association
utopia 56 et bien elle se charge de ces
personnes elles essayent de les reloger
de faire en sorte et bien qu'ils ne
dorment pas dans les rues en tout cas ce
soir ils vont peut-être pas c est la
nuit ici ils seront évacués peut-être
dans la matinée dans la journée on ne
sait pas encore en tout cas pour le
moment pas d'intervention des forces de
l'ordre
vous le voyez encore juste derrière moi
une ambiance plutôt calme
pas de tension jusqu'à présent juste ces
personnes qui essayent d'alerter le
gouvernement les autorités d'une mii
pour une mise à l'abri immédiate
merci mon amour et laure accompagné de
leucate ua pour les images en direct
donc de la place de la république
on parlait de la crise sanitaire en
france la crise sanitaire évidemment à
l'échelle européenne avec la belgique
qui optent pour un re confinement strict
de quatre semaines contrairement à la
france des écoles des commerces seront
fermés dès ce week-end mais il reste
possible de se déplacer malgré le
couvre-feu également maintenu les
précisions de maxime hébert bruxelles
n'aura pas traîné
avec une semaine d'avancé sur son
calendrier le comité de concertation
sorte de conseil de défense belge
s'est réuni en urgence ce mercredi
l'objectif répondre au plus vite à la
flambée de l'épidémie dans le plat pays
alexander de croo s'est donc présenté
devant la presse à l'issue de cette
réunion le premier ministre belge a
annoncé un durcissement des mesures anti
qu'ovide pour les quatre prochaines
semaines
face à la hausse des contaminations
c'est clair que c'était une décision
difficile et que pour beaucoup de gens
c'était une déception
et c'est pesant c'est nous deux va
prendre ces décisions là mais si on ne
prendrait pas ses décisions là les
conséquences seraient clairement encore
plus grave que ce qu'on voit maintenant
avec 40% de contamination dans les
entreprises
l'assouplissement de ces derniers mois
est bel et bien oublié rouvert depuis
début décembre les commerces ou non
alimentaires ne fonctionneront plus que
sur rendez vous eux étaient ouverts
depuis mi-février les métiers de contact
non médical comme l'état thouars où les
coiffeurs devront également baissé le
rideau
prévue pour le 1er avril le plan plein
air qui prévoyait la reprise des
activités culturelles et des pratiques
de culte est finalement mise en pause
les rassemblements en extérieur de plus
de quatre personnes sont également
interdits enfin dès lundi toutes les
écoles à l'exception des écoles
maternelles fermeront leurs grilles un
mal nécessaire pour le premier ministre
mais qui ne satisfait pas le ministre
flamand de l'enseignement les dernières
semaines nous avons travaillé ensemble
avec le secteur de l'enseignement pour
pouvoir garder les écoles ouvertes de
manière sûre nous nous sommes accrochés
à la conviction que en tant que société
nous devons donner priorité à
l'enseignement à nos enfants et jeunes
non les enfants à l'école ne sont pas le
moteur du virus
la belgique est particulièrement touché
par le variant britannique devenu
majoritaire parmi les contaminations et
invariants belge vient même d'être
découvert avec 200 décès pour cent mille
habitants
la belgique est le cinquième pays le
plus endeuillé au monde par la crise
sanitaire
côté vaccination 11,4 pour cent de sa
population âgée de plus de 18 ans a reçu
une première dose de vaccin
un chiffre supérieur à son voisin
français et pas du tout la même chose en
israël où ils font un pas de plus vers
la liberté la moitié de la population a
reçu deux doses de vaccin 13h biotech
soit plus de 4 millions six cent mille
israéliens selon les statistiques du
ministère de la santé publié aujourd'hui
grâce à cette vaccination de masse
l'épidémie continue de reculer dans le
pays
seuls quatre cent soixante dix nouveaux
cas ont été enregistrés aujourd'hui et
le taux de contamination de la
population n'a cessé de baisser
s'établissant 1,1 pour cent contre près
de 6% fin février et précisons de paula
slayer journalistes pour rt
international minutes les deux
communautés les plus réticents à la
vaccination sont la communauté
religieuse ultra orthodoxes et la
communauté arabe
le gouvernement et les autorités sont en
contact avec les dirigeants de ces
communautés et on voit également des
centres de vaccination mobile
littéralement au coeur de ces
communautés
lorsque le centre de vaccination et
devant la porte de quelqu'un il est bien
plus simple de se faire vacciner
le passeport vert qui est délivrée après
avoir reçu deux doses du vaccin est
également une incitation forte
il ya des contrôles de ces passeports
vert à l'entrée d'hôtels de restaurants
et de concerts ce qui pousse beaucoup de
personnes a souhaité se faire vacciner
enfin la fête juive de pessah début de
samedi soir à la même période l'année
dernière
les gens passaient pessah chez eux sans
pouvoir se réunir en famille
l'idée de pouvoir se rassembler en
famille pour les nombreuses fêtes juives
et donc également un facteur de
motivation
les israéliens reprennent ouvertement
leur vie normale
l'aéroport qui était fermé pendant la
majeure partie du mois a rouvert et les
vols internationaux au départ et à
l'arrivée ont repris même si les
arrivants doivent toujours passé une
semaine d'isolement chez eux ou dans un
hôtel s'ils n'ont pas reçu les deux
doses du vaccin les salles de sport sont
ouvertes à 70 % c'est-à-dire qu'elle
opère à une jauge de 70%
mais pour se rendre à un concert à un
événement culturel ou au restaurant
il faut présenter un passeport vert j'y
vois même voulu réserver une table au
restaurant hier et tout était complet
pour les deux semaines à venir
les israéliens n'ont donc pas perdu de
temps pour retrouver le pays et leur vie
d'avant le coronavirus le passeport vert
n'est valide que pour six mois et on ne
sait pas ce qui se passe après six mois
il n'y a pas eu de décision officielle
ou en tout cas pas de déclaration par le
ministère de la santé où le premier
ministre
mais on pense qu'il aura des rappels à
prendre dans les six mois c'est un sujet
que le pays va devoir étudier en
profondeur dans l'intervalle pessah
approche ainsi que le jour de
l'indépendance et yom hashoah la journée
du souvenir pour la première fois depuis
longtemps il y aura de grands
rassemblements en extérieur pour ces
événements mais israël maintient
toujours le port du masque et la
distanciation physique donc cela au
moins là resté pendant longtemps
l'europe en sommet virtuel aujourd'hui
une réunion marquée par la participation
de joe biden une première pour le 46e
président des etats-unis qui a prononcé
un discours
une intervention dans laquelle
il a évoqué plusieurs sujets et fait des
annonces fortes aux premiers plants joe
biden qui indique qu'il sera à nouveau
candidat pour 2024 sur le plan
international il précise ne pas vouloir
de confrontation avec la chine et se
fixe également un objectif vacciner 200
millions d'américains dans les 100
premiers jours de son mandat
aujourd'hui je me fixe un deuxième
objectif
si le 100e jour de mandat nous aurons
administrés 200 millions de vaccins dans
les bras des gens c'est exact 200
millions de vaccins en 100 jours
je sais que c'est ambitieux que c'est le
double de notre objectif initial mais
aucun autre pays au monde ne s'en est
approché même pas de près de ce que nous
faisons je crois que nous pouvons faire
est toujours aux états unis interdiction
aux journalistes de couvrir les crises
migratoires à la frontière mexicaine
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de joe biden
ce que dénoncent les républicains
l'administration maiden est accusé
d'avoir provoqué un flux de migrants la
frontière et de ne plus pouvoir le gérer
solène goda une seule caméra pour
accompagner la délégation de washington
en visite dans un camp de migrants
mineurs à la frontière mexicaine annonce
ce mercredi de la porte-parole de la
maison blanche
laroque et une caméra pour fera partie
de ce voyage et veillera à ce qu'une
couverture des 9 poules soit fourni à
toutes les chaînes afin que vous
puissiez tous vous rendre compte par
vous-même et proposer une analyse de ces
images ces images parfois floue tourné à
carrizo springs au texas sont les seuls
refusé diffusée par toutes les chaînes
de télévision américaines
un traitement médiatique très
confidentielle justifiée par la crise
sanitaire selon washington
mais qui déclenche une vague
d'indignation dans une tribune publiée
dans le washington post le photographe
de presse john moore auteur d'un ouvrage
sur la frontière entre les etats-unis et
le mexique dénonce un manque de
transparence faisant même un
rapprochement entre joe biden et son
prédécesseur donald trump
nous sommes passés de la politique de
tolérance zéro de l'air trump envers les
immigrants à une politique d'accès 0 de
leur bail donne pour les journalistes
couvrant l'immigration cette évolution
est sans précédent dans l'histoire
moderne
même critique de ce célèbre sénateur
républicain au texas l'administration
bailon à imposer une obligation de
silence une interdiction aux médias à
devenir pendant quatre ans nous avons
entendu les démocrates parler sans cesse
d'enfants en cage et bien joe biden ne
veut absolument pas qui vous voyait les
cages de baden sa solution est de dire
un de caméras pad équipe de télévision
pas de médias pendant sa campagne
présidentielle joe biden avait promis de
mener une politique migratoire plus
humaine et plus transparente
ce mercredi le président américain a
remis ce dossier entre les mains de la
vice-présidente kamala harris une tâche
difficile at il concédé
tenu pour le moment à l'écart des
journalistes
reste avec mon dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des agriculteurs en
colère ils ont défilé à lyon et clermont
ferrand il dénonce la loi et gally mais
le projet de réforme de la politique
agricole commune
et puis direction la libye où le
gouvernement
nationale appelle au retrait immédiat
des forces étrangères tout comme les
chefs de la diplomatie française
allemande et italienne en visite
aujourd'hui à tripoli
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent
j'appelle en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus
extrêmes à dallas de cette 11e
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île vers view
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le maniement de la rumeur est vieux
comme le monde mais il est vrai que
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité l'influencent a pris
toute sa place au coeur des
affrontements politiques et économiques
internationaux car elle est une
manifestation de la puissance capable de
peser sur l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée car
la vérité finit toujours par éclater
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash vous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment vous jugez avec vous la
situation aujourd'hui après plus d'un an
de crise le tourisme est probablement
l'une des filières qui souffrent le plus
de la crise sanitaire le tourisme et
l'événementiel c'est à dire en fait tout
ce qui crée des flux de population tout
ce qui crée des rassemblements comment
vous voyez là les possibilités de faire
redémarrer tout ça le rôle des élus en
ce moment qu'ils soient nationaux ou
locaux
c'est de trouver le juste équilibre
entre la protection sanitaire et donc la
disparition du virus à terme et la vie
économique et la vie sociale
on voit bien que y'a pas que la vie
économique qui est touché il ya toute la
psychologie des gens c'est trop long
donc il faut ajuster les protocoles
sanitaires à une vie économique
culturelle sportive événementielle qui
puisse renaître
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme à au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est à dire là qui
sont embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils
ont été manipulés et d'autres qui
agissent de manière parfaitement
consciente et lucide je respecterai
toujours l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
il est 21h30 souhaité bienvenue en
direct sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez ils étaient quelques milliers
d'agriculteurs à s'être donné rendez
vous dans le centre de clermont ferrand
et à lyon également pour protester
contre la loi et gally mais demande une
politique agricole commune
illustration de la journée à clermont
ferrand par valentin carpentier une
scène inhabituelle dans les rues de lyon
des dizaines de tracteurs d'agriculteurs
ont investi la ville en fin de matinée
après une opération escargot sur le
réseau routier lyonnais venus du rhône
de l'ain et de la drôme
les véhicules avec des remorques
chargées de pneus et de fumier ont
encerclé la place bellecour
objectif de ces agriculteurs dénoncer
les promesses non tenues par emmanuel
macron est pointé du doigt
l'inefficacité de la loyale hymne un
dispositif censé leur garantir une plus
juste rémunération
bien sûr qu on time à perdre puisqu'on a
des revenus qui sont trop insuffisant et
qu'on peut considérer comme à perte
puisque on a beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui
sont entre à peine à 1000 euros de
revenus nets par mois c'est inadmissible
par rapport aux eur qu'on peut passer
jusqu'à un agriculteur fait à peu près
entre 60 et 70 heures par semaine
une action coup de poing qui s'est
déroulée sans débordement après avoir
été reçue à la préfecture du rhône
les agriculteurs ont annoncé l'obtention
d'un rendez vous avec le ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
julien de normandie la victoire se
concrétisera en début de semaine derni
délais quand on aura les annonces du
ministre mes annonces concrètes et pas
des belles paroles et belles paroles en
aveugle nous faut aujourd'hui des
engagements écrits
qui se traduiront par une modification
de la loi et y allume le départ des
protestataires a eu lieu dans le calme
comme le reste de la journée mais les
agriculteurs ont mis en garde les
autorités
si rien ne change d'ici les vacances de
pâques lui on sera de nouveau envahi par
les tracteurs et cette fois ci la
manifestation pourrait être bien plus
agité un bon soir romain de leyritz
président des jeunes agriculteurs de
l'aveyron merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france pour parler de
ces manifestations qui ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui en france qu'est ce que vous
reprochez le plus à cette loi
alimentation dite loi et galim or je
crois qu'elle a suscité beaucoup
d'espoir dans le nombre de paysans ou
monde paysan à espérer juste retour de
la valeur dans les fermes avec un
principe de construction du prix à
marchands c'est-à-dire important
découdre again à des producteurs et en
additionnant les coups de deux
transformations et les marges des
différents intermédiaires ce principe là
aujourd'hui n'est absolument pas
respectée dans aucune filière l'ensemble
des filières agricoles travailler à
construire le alors que de leur coût de
revient et qui ne sont pas ils ne sont
pas pris en compte au delà de la
construction et dans le prix de vente
ça veut dire ça me remet un des derniers
de pardon que cette loi il n'est pas si
mal mais qu'en fait elle n'est pas
respectée et cela oui sur le principe je
pense qu'on touche eu beaucoup de votre
centre et positifs qu'on comporte de nos
coups d'oreillers
mais elle n'est pas assez contraignantes
vis-à-vis des distributeurs longtemps
puisque même si le principe est positif
le résultat n'est pas là donc ils
manquent
il manque des choses avec nous on n'est
pas suffisamment contraignant pour que
la valeur vient alors serge papin
justement l'ancien patron du système u 1
a été
mandaté début octobre pour trouver les
moyens d'aller plus loin que cette loi
est galim l'une de ses principales
recommandations consiste à rendre
obligatoire la signature d'un contrat
pluriannuel entre l'agriculteur et
l'industriel qui va donc transformer ces
produits est ce que c'est la bonne voie
c'est la bonne solution selon vous on
peut prendre toutes les meilleures
initiatives du monde
si nous serons respectés ça ne sert à
rien donc
appliquons déjà aujourd'hui ce qui a
déjà été fait en vain de vouloir être
déjà allée plus loin il une fois que
l'un samedi les critères qui doivent
être respectées le second ont des
gravats la nécessité d'aller d'aller
plus loin mais il faut il faut
absolument de durcir juge t il renforcer
les contrôles sur le dispositif qui
existe qui existent ça veut dire qu'un
gouvernement lieu comme vous dites
d'appliquer les choses peut-être
dépenses son temps et son argent avec
des énième rapport qui dans le fond vont
ne servir à rien parce que l'ambition
paraissait plutôt louable sur le papier
oui oui sur le papier on est gay et ces
idées là ce qu'on s'a le coc semble on
le partage à l'initiative on peut on ne
peut on peut y adhérer à près de 6000
constatations sur l'a22 production c'est
que c'est que le résultat nul est loin
du compte
pour donner un exemple précis tout le
moins depuis ce drame la filière
laitière google et a fait le calcul
qu'il faudrait que les éleveurs son pays
nos 2 400 euros la tonne de lait ynwa
dignement de leur métier
aujourd'hui sur le lit que j'ai vendu
sur le mois de février
le prix de base s'est même pas 330 euros
donc on est là tous les cars qui reste à
combler pour émuler dignement justement
le travail des éleveurs romande et
lhérisson
on a du mal à comprendre cette quoi
mauvaise volonté de la part des
industriels pour vous avez en face
comment vous l'expliquez que soit soit
aussi compliqué aussi peu équitable pour
vous à gries culteurs donc je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs aspects le premier
qui le premier qui me vient en tête
c'est le fait que ou lobby agro 62 % de
l'alimentation est apte et en grande
surface et que face aux agriculteurs il
ya quatre opérateurs
on va pas citer le nom de tout le monde
les tout le monde ne les croyez donc il
n'y a pas encore de force totalement
défavorable aux agriculteurs le prochain
sujet
optiquement aussi très sensible à dire
la puissance publique les politiques
s'incline devant devant on va dire la
défense du pour des plaques que
revendique notamment jean-michel
d'angleterre au détriment des
producteurs de destruction de filières
dans de valeur dans les filières la
destruction de deux filières entières de
quelques centimes de plus
au kilo de viande ou sur le coup sûr
litres de lait permettent de le lay
correctement les économies c'est pas
c'est pas un gros c'est pas un gros
effort c'est juste quelques centimes qui
permettait collectivement aux éleveurs
de vivre correctement de leur bêtise
super fait des romanes et des risques
les consommateurs seraient tout à fait
prêt à faire cet effort maintenant est
ce que les industriels les supermarchés
le sont parce qu'apparemment la balle
est dans leur camp quel serait le moyen
pour les consommateurs de plus vous
aider de ces français en premier lieu je
pense que c'est le premier c'est le
premier signe que les consommateurs
peuvent peuvent faire pour soutenir leur
culture l'agriculture française désignée
plusieurs années positivement la culture
la plus durable au monde donc mais que
les aggies que les consommateurs
français se tournent déjà un priorité
dans les relais police racing que la
restauration collective je les répare
par les collectivités locales à penser
de même je connais cet engouement est
que le consommateur ça me ferait
français sur le premier ambassadeur de
ce malgré tueur merci en tout cas à
romain des v10 président des jeunes
agriculteurs de l'aveyron merci en tout
cas d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur
rt france à marseille la question du
logement suscite toujours la polémique
et les autorités se rejettent la faute
et préfère ne pas s'exprimer alors que
des milliers de personnes vivent dans
des appartements insalubres
la mairie de la ville a pris des
initiatives mais les retombées concrètes
restent insuffisantes selon les
associations
françois xavier lambert en 2017 jennifer
tout juste arrivé à marseille et loup en
urgence en petit studio situé dans le
centre de la ville elle ne se doute pas
au premier coup d'oeil qu'il s'agit d'un
local à vélos loués 520 euros par mois
les odeurs dans le logement dépourvu de
système de ventilation deviennent
rapidement nauséabonde et les
moisissures envahissent progressivement
le petit espace alors que jennifer
demande à son propriétaire d'agir elle
découvre que ce dernier est un adjoint
au maire de la ville face à son absence
de réponse elle décide de saisir la
justice
moi j'avais vraiment envie que la
justice fasse son travail
pas forcément envie de demander des
dommages et intérêts watchers parce
qu'elle apprenne demande même pas de çà
mau autres matchs jusqu en fait c'est
annuler mon bail stipule vraiment que
c'est un local à vélo quand j'ai habité
et moi j'ai vraiment signer pour un
logement et noir local à vélo donc quand
je me suis présenté au procès c'est vrai
que j'étais très énervé j'étais en quête
de justice
aujourd'hui la jeune femme occupe une
confortable studio et s'apprête en avril
prochain à revenir au tribunal
les héritiers du propriétaire décédé ont
fait appel en première instance il a été
condamné à lui rembourser tous les
loyers ainsi qu'à lui verser 2000 euros
de dommages et intérêts la famille
bouzekri vite elle aussi dans un
logement insalubre situé dans le
quartier populaire de noailles depuis
leur emménagement le propriétaire ne
veut pas rénové et ne vient pas
constater les problèmes de l'appartement
loué 550 euros par mois
la mairie a pourtant jugé le logement
insalubre ce qui autorise la famille
plus payer le loyer tant que le
propriétaire n'a pas effectué les
travaux nécessaires mais celui ci n'a
toujours pas réagi faisant pas de
regarder pendant qu'elle connaît pas nos
prêts internes elle vénère la première
fois dans l'argent pour l'appartement
mais c'est un savant c'est bon elle dans
le jeu et les fortes aujourd'hui
évocatoire le prêt venez je n'ai pas de
s'arranger l'effroi pour le bébé pour
mes enfants
oui oui oui devenu face aux nombreuses
habitations marseillaise en salubre le
collectif du 5 novembre tente de faire
bouger les pouvoirs locaux
emmanuel patrice urbaniste de formation
est l'un des membres actifs de
l'association
il déplore que la ville de marseille et
la métropole n'agissent pas et se
renvoient la balle au lieu de restaurer
l'habitat marseillais on a perdu deux
ans et demi depuis les effondrements de
la rue d'aubagne
en gros depuis cette annonce rien ou
presque s'est passé c'est un bilan
factuel catastrophique qu'on fait qu'on
fait aujourd'hui ça c'est un sujet qui
clairement et est problématique pour
pour les institutions parce que c'est un
chantier énorme a apporté quoi
selon le rapport nicole en 2015 il
existait 40000 taudis à marseille soit
cent mille personnes sur huit cent
soixante mille habitants qui vivaient
dans des logements insalubres
depuis l'effondrement rue d'aubagne le 5
novembre 2018
la mairie a procédé à cinq mille
évacuation mais 95 mille personnes sont
toujours concernés par l'insalubrité de
leurs logements
la ville de marseille et la métropole
n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer sur la
situation
visite aujourd'hui des chefs de la
diplomatie française allemande et
italienne en libye dix jours après avoir
investi un gouvernement de transition et
près de 10 ans après déclenchement d'un
conflit particulièrement violent alors
le pays serait-il en train de reprendre
espoir éléments de réponse avec pierre
qui savent hivernaux c'est dans le but
d'accompagner d'encourager la transition
politique dans le pays que jean yves le
drian et comme as et luigi di maio se
sont rendus en terre libyenne ce jeudi
une dizaine de jours après son
installation officielle
le gouvernement de transition prend peu
à peu ses marques pour tenter de mettre
fin à dix ans de conflit la stabilité à
voilà donc l'un des nouveaux objectifs
de cette équipe ministérielle issus du
processus de réconciliation nationale
une mission périlleuse à laquelle la
france pourrait prochainement contribuer
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a laissé
entendre il ya quelques jours emmanuel
macron ça n'est pas simplement un
soutien de mots de façade c'est un
soutien complet qui sera celui de la
france d'abord parce que nous avons une
dette à l'égard de la libye et des
libyens très clair qui est une décennie
de désordre les forces étrangères qui
sont sur le sol libyen le kit au plus
vite possible
si la situation semble s'être apaisé la
question des nombreux combattants armés
présents dans le pays se pose toujours
d'après l'onu ils seraient près de 20000
tous principalement étrangers est
toujours actif ces derniers mois comme
la ministre libyenne des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian demande
leur départ le départ des mercenaires
est essentielle pour que l'état libyen
affirme sa souveraineté de la même
manière la stabilité de la libye est une
des clés de la stabilité du sahel de
l'afrique du nord de la méditerranée
parmi ces combattants armés des syriens
déployés par la turquie aurait commencé
à se retirer d'après une source
diplomatique française
après un cessez-le-feu proclamé en
octobre dernier prochaine échéance
cruciale pour la libye des élections
générales prévues pour décembre 2021
et pour en parler nous sommes avec riadh
sidaoui expert du monde arabe directeur
du centre arabe de recherche et
d'analysé politique et sociale un bon
soir
d oui merci d'être avec nous alors
bonsoir que dit cette visite de ces
chefs de la diplomatie européens que le
pays est en voie de normalisation
oui ce sont des signes est en fait
positif il ya marathon le président kaïs
haidar s'est rendu à tripoli et
rencontrer son homologue libyen a lui
même fait la même chose de président les
biens le président du conseil ministre
libyen s'est rendu à en egypte a
rencontré à traiter à 6 6 et 3 ministres
des affaires étrangères européens sont
aujourd'hui à tripoli
ce sont de bons signes en même temps on
n'entend pas les armes
on n'entend pas la voir des arbres
n'entend pas les militaires les milices
si le politique maintenant et le
diplomate et qui priment sur les
militaires s'ils sont des bons bon signe
espérons que ça va continuer mais malgré
tout la libye actuellement est divisée
entre est et ouest et la ligne du cirque
juste moi je fera partager réellement
aimer les thermaux la libye entre deux
cons alors on va en parler de ces deux
pendant quelques minutes mais mais
restons sur cette visite des européens
comment analyser la déclaration d'
emmanuel macron propos de la libye nous
avons une dette envers la libye très
clair une décennie de désordre liquide
et le même regret que barack obama avant
de partir avant de quitter la maison
blanche a exprimé son regret et l'a dit
la libye s'est plongée et plongée dans
le chaos et je regrette
et aujourd'hui c'est la même chose c'est
presque le même discours qui se répètent
sans des bonnes paroles moi je trouve ça
assez
c'est un pas positif mais il faut dire
que cette décennie noire pour le public
c'est une décennie de da a chassé le
déjà bardé d islamiste de terroriste et
d une déchirure
des dizaines de milliers de victimes les
biens et l'économique s'est effondré
donc le peuple et bien beaucoup souffert
a beaucoup se faire et je pense les
bonnes paroles ne peut pas à confronter
à réconforter le drame d'une décennie
d'une population qui est la population
libyenne mais mais c'est que ça reste
aussi un signe positif comme barack
obama l'a dit avant de partir avant de
quitter la maison
alors on sait que la france hélas
l'italie sont très impliqués et on sait
aussi que c'est une route privilégié à
une route migratoire privilégié vers
vers l'europe ceci explique cela
oui l'italie dialogue de très bons
rapports avec la libye même pendant la
réunion de gaddafi l'aï beaucoup de
contrats et l'allée l'italien colisée
aussi la libye nous n'oublions pas ça et
je pense que l'allemagne aussi à jouer
un rôle à berlin dans la conférence de
l'est bien je pense à partir de la
conférence de berlin
les libyens ont commencé sérieusement
cette fois ci de trouver un chemin afin
de trouver une solution politique et
durable d'union nationale c'est à partir
de cette conférence de berlin donc
l'allemagne a joué un grand rôle
la france aussi l'italie aussi et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de facteurs
positifs aux jeunes aujourd'hui qui se
dope où se regroupent afin de trouver
solution pacifique et permanente où les
libyens parce que les libyens ont
beaucoup beaucoup ce faire j'ai beaucoup
d'amis à triaud à bengazi et unique
spring toujours toujours leur chagrine
exprime toujours leurs souffrances
alors parmi les pistes de stabilisation
du pays évidemment la réunification vous
en parlais tout à l'heure entre l'est et
l'ouest 1 qui sont portées par le
nouveau gouvernement d'union nationale
on peut y croire à cette réunification
selon vous au plan opérationnel c'est
très difficile
l'expérience l'a montré parce qu'on a
une nounou des seniors des guerres ils
sont enrichis grâce à cette guerre
civile à l'est nous savons bien que
l'alarmé national libyen composé depuis
par des officiers de gaddafi mais
dirigée par l'américain kraft à l'ouest
il ya plusieurs islamistes la plupart
sont des islamistes des milices
islamistes surtout à tripoli elias
interne aussi à l'ouest il ya thomas au
sud donc les protagonistes armées sont
nombreux surtout à l'ouest est excusé
comment on comment faire comment comment
fait construire l'état libyen il faut
avoir le monopole de la violence
légitime comme le dit max weber
ça veut dire une seule armée nationale
et celle police nationale
mais que faire comment faire la tâche
est très très difficile et hardy
d'ailleurs aussi à camille-guibert
parler d'un miracle devant le parlement
le gâteau broc l'addition arrive à
unifier les institutions libyennes déjà
fait un miracle parce que les cautions
peu la tâche est très très difficile sur
le terrain
est ce que les militaires les milices
vont céder leurs armes facilement
j'ai des forts doutes alors on le
retrait des forces étrangères ont
réclamé par les etats-unis et les
européens ce qu'elles sont primordiales
pour accélérer le processus de paix
absolument absolument parce que les
ingérences étrangères les interventions
des forces militaires étrangères
ils ont aggravé la situation libyenne
notamment l'arrivée de l'armée turque à
tripoli
la turquie a envahi carrément tripoli
aussi bien d'autres présences on parle
des conseillers militaires égyptiens à
l'est ou d'asie mais raté ou même une
présence aux russes mais mais évidemment
les plus dangereux sont les terroristes
les intégristes sont venus avec l'armée
turque sont venues de la syrie parce que
nous impose de proposer toujours les
questions où sont ils passés les
terroristes de dh de reclasser de
mousson certainement il ya pas mal qui
sont olivier actuellement
merci à riadh sidaoui expérience rare
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france dans le reste d'actualité il ya
six ans jour pour jour le yémen entrer
dans un conflit qui n'en finit ses
patrons n'en finit pas même une guerre
qui oppose les rebelles houthi et le
gouvernement soutenu par ryad
malgré les dizaines de milliers de morts
est la pire catastrophe humanitaire au
monde selon les nations unies les
combats continuent dans l'indifférence
générale
scarlett bas avec quentin mots clairs
il ya qui devait être est clair et qui
s'est transformé en guerre d'usure
lancé en janvier 2015 par le prince
héritier saoudien mohammed bin salman
son objectif est clair remettre au
pouvoir le président yéménite renversé
par les rebelles houthi ali abdallah
saleh cette opération devait selon ses
propres mots ne durer que deux jours
il est appuyé par une coalition de neuf
pays menée par l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis et les moyens
militaires déployés sont considérables
malgré cela la coalition n'est toujours
pas venu à bout des rebelles houthi ryad
a même été directement touchées par des
tirs de missiles un fiasco militaire au
prix de bombardements meurtriers qui
touchent durement les civils aux
disparus s'ajoutent les millions de
déplacés et la famille provoquée par le
blocus mis en place par la coalition
une situation décrit par l'onu comme la
pire crise humanitaire au monde
cette wave m la situation au yémen est
catastrophique
c'est la pire crise humanitaire sur
terre avec 16 millions de personnes en
réelles situations d'urgence et 5
millions qui sous couvre aimons à famine
sur lyon
si nous n'obtenons pas l'argent dont
nous avons besoin est le carburant nous
allons probablement avoir la pire famine
qu'ait jamais connue devant cette
situation plusieurs pays décident
d'arrêter leurs ventes d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite
c'est le cas notamment de l'italie et
des etats-unis joe biden
la france elle reste pour le moment
muette en 2019
elle occupait la troisième place sur le
podium des vendeurs d'armes fournissant
ainsi 7,9 pour cent du marché mondial
le secteur de l'industrie de défense est
un secteur très important pour la
technologie française et pour notre
économie pour nos emplois je n'ai aucune
information me permettant d'assurer que
ces victimes civiles le son du fait des
armes françaises
acculé dans ses positions sur le terrain
militaire est affaibli par les
défections de ses principaux alliés
internationaux
l'arabie saoudite a proposé ce lundi un
cessez le feu total aux outils
proposition rejetée
car elle tombe à un moment où leurs
adversaires sont sur le point de prendre
la ville stratégique de m'arrive c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
pierre pissavy yvernault
[Musique]
vas-y tu es pour tous ce que ça apporte
aux ans